that's your boy durian here with
Collider video and I'm here at the
castle of Ruby from roosterteeth so guys
can you go ahead and just uh what
characters are you playing and who he
voicing and can you guys tease what was
for the upcoming season six
I am Lindsay Jones and I played the
voice of Ruby Rose hi my name is Kara
Everly and I voiced Weiss Schnee and
Ruby and I wish I could talk more about
what's going on in season six mcc's itíd
though it's gonna be awesome
I went in when I was like what after
reading the scripts all I can say is
you're gonna say what I'm Erin Zach and
I voice Blake belladonna and I'm Barbara
uncle min and I am voice yang Xiao long
I want to say it's a girl Barbara cuz
you went it's your boy I wanted to do it
but yeah season six obviously we know
team Ruby's back together so I think a
lot of people are excited about that and
see what they get up to next you guys
first started the show did you guys
think it would have such a big impact on
roosterteeth in the future of the
company yeah we definitely one we were
just worried about like our fan base in
general liking the show I mean Monty
described it as a passion project or
like this would be something that we
would do and it would be somewhat
successful and fun and we would move on
with our lives so to not only have our
dedicated fan base like it but now we
have external fan bases including a
large Asian population that we had never
broken into you before
I mean we're being dubbed in Japan by
some of the top list voice actors there
it's it's insane we never thought this
would happen
yeah I mean especially to be here for
you know our our fifth or sixth RGX as
rude as team rwby it's that's crazy time
flies and I feel like we're getting so
old same time it's like it's it's fun
and refreshing every year to see what
all the new cosplays people come up with
and all the new characters it's always
always an exciting experience I mean
it's it's changed our lives and that
sounds you know cliche and cheesy but
it's absolutely true I thought you said
topless actor actors and I was like what
fun Ruby ya know I'm super excited I
actually haven't seen too much of what's
happening in the next volume so I get to
get excited just like everybody else we
never expected Ruby to grow into what it
has become it's just incredible to see
every year RTX people go crazy for it
but also now we get to go to conventions
around the world as well and meet fans
everywhere and every single time I'm
surprised like there
this many people in this particular city
who want to see us and it's just insane
to know how many people around the world
in the US are just crazy about Ruby like
we are we have Jim Locke coming out in
2019
maybe I don't think any guys can
probably answer this but could there
even be a chance of a Jim Locke Ruby
crossover in the future would you got
would you guys want to see something
like that I don't think it's really a
spoiler but tonight we have the genlock
panel at 7 o'clock and you might be
seeing a few characters and some
familiar faces from roosterteeth and
that's also another thing we we
definitely like are very excited to have
Jen lock release and obviously being
part of Ruby it's exciting to have
another animated show we definitely want
to let Jen Lanka live on its own and not
have people associate oh this is the
people that make Ruby but Jen Locke is
such an incredible production on its own
that we want to make sure it has its own
voice and its own legs as well I think
we'll end it on that guys thank you guys
so much Ruby and when can we expect Ruby
season six so we're looking at a fall
release right now we're looking for an
October release date but it's definitely
gonna be at the end of this year so get
excited already here make sure to tune
in it's gonna be late
thank you guys